"Moments later, it started to become clear.
Someone was trudging through the water behind
us and coming for our boat."
Hello, and welcome to Al Dente Creepypasta,
horror stories cooked to perfection with a
splash of red sauce.
My name is CZ, and I will be your server this
episode.
Today’s story is set at the happiest place
on earth.
But even the happiest places have a dark side.
Let's dig right in.
Sean: “Come on Tom, let’s go!
Let’s go!”
Hear that annoying voice rushing me out the
door?
That’s my little brother Sean.
Today I’d be responsible for escorting Sean
and his friend Nick, to Disneyland for his
birthday.
Sure, I wasn’t looking forward to getting
up early, nor was I looking forward to keeping
an eye on two 11 year olds all day, but I
have to admit, I was kind of excited to spend
the day at Disney.
It had been a long time my parents had taken
me there, so I was kind of looking forward
to revisiting the likes of Space Mountain,
Haunted Mansion and of course: Pirates of
the Caribbean.
What I hadn't taken into account, was that
my brother had never been to Disney, so although
he was excited, when we actually got there
and he saw the size of everything, Sean became
a little bit more timid.
We had to work our way up to the more exciting
attractions.
For me, this was a bit of a drag.
I wasn’t exactly looking forward to riding
Peter Pan or Buzz Lightyear when I told my
mom I would take him to the park for the day.
And while I do admit that the Buzz Lightyear
ride is actually pretty fun, I made sure to
gradually acclimate him to the thrill rides
as well, starting with the Gadget Go Coaster
to Big Thunder and eventually hitting Matterhorn
Bobsleds and even Space Mountain.
It was getting close to dusk when I suggested
we check out Pirates of the Caribbean.
Sean had been hesitant about it all day.
I tried to explain that it was much tamer
than Space Mountain or any of the coasters
we had been on that day.
But he resisted.
There is something about being in a boat and
being in the dark that didn't sit well with
him.
But with a little arm twisting, and with the
added element of him not wanting to look like
a pussy in front of his friend, I was able
to get Pirates on our agenda that evening.
As we queued, I could see my brother starting
to get nervous.
He does this thing where he runs his hands
through his hair when he's nervous, and right
now his hair was a mess.
There was something different about this time
though.
Sure, he did this during all the lines for
rides he was nervous to go on, he just had
this look in his eye that was somehow different
when we were standing in line for Pirates.
I told myself that he'd get over it once he'd
experienced the ride once, and tried not to
make a big deal out it.
He kept on asking me questions.
“How many drops are there?
Do you get wet?
Does it go pitch black?
Will the Pirates touch you?”
I just about couldn't take anymore incessant
pestering by the time we'd reached the front
of the line.
Our boat pulled into the station and we filed
in, sticking with the usual seating arrangement
of Nick, Sean, then me.
But then, Sean had jumped out of his seat
and crossed over to the right side of the
station.
“I…
I don't wanna go.”
He stuttered.
“Come on…”
I told him.
“This ride’s nothing.”
Then his friend Nick jumped out and offered
to skip the ride with him.
Great.
My one bargaining tool was gone.
“You can go.
We'll meet you by the exit.”
I considered this for a moment.
Mom would probably kill me if she knew I'd
let them go by themselves.
Still, we'd waited for so long, and this was
one of my favorite rides.
He was 11 years old now.
And they were together.
What's the worst that could happen?
“Fine.
But you stay together.
And meet me right by the exit.”
And with that, Nick and Sean disappeared into
the dark of the synthetic bayou.
My boat took off.
I was in the third row.
In front of me were two parents and their
young son.
And the front row was occupied by two kids,
about Sean's age, and their Mom.
Seeing them momentarily made me regret leaving
Sean and Nick on their own.
Perhaps they weren't old enough to look after
themselves yet.
I made myself wash that thought away with
the soothing sounds of the swamp.
(Sounds)
But as those sounds faded away, I felt a chill
go up my spine.
“Ye come seekin’ adventure and salty ol’
Pirates, eh?
Sure ye come to the proper place.
But keep a weather eye open, mates, and hold
on tight, with both hands if you please…
there be squalls ahead, and Davy Jones waiting
for them what don't obey..
”
The kid in front of me grabbed onto his Dad's
arm for comfort.
This was it.
The first and biggest drop that the ride had
to offer.
I threw my hands into the air and the kids
around me screamed as we plunged down into
the darkness…
only… something was not right when we splashed
down at the bottom.
For one, it was still pitch black.
Usually this part of the ride was lit with
blue and green colored lights that accented
the inside of the cavern.
The other difference was the lack of music.
The bottom of the drop should be accompanied
by the song, A Pirate’s Life For Me.
But instead all I could hear was the crashing
of water around me, echoing in every which
direction off the cavernous walls.
I could no longer see the kids and parents
in front of me, as the area was pitch black,
but I could hear one them crying, and the
parents trying to comfort him.
To be fair, that kid had every right to be
scared.
Because as anyone who’s ridden the ride
knows there was a second drop coming, but
with no light or sound to tip us off as to
when it would happen, it could come at any
moment.
All we had to go on was the crashing sounds
of the waterfall getting louder and louder.
I felt my stomach drop hard, when it happened,
and I have to say, those drops feel much faster
and scarier in the complete dark.
But after that, we just floated.
I honestly could barely tell if we were going
anywhere.
I know we had drifted away from the drop but
even as my eyes adjusted to the dark, I still
could not see much of anything.
I began to wonder if it was just the show
that was broken, or if the entire ride system
was down.
My biggest fear was getting stuck on the ride
and Sean and Nick, not knowing what to do
wandering off.
There was some chatter from the other guests.
The kids asking what would happen.
The parents and myself trying to figure out
what to do.
There was no cell reception.
At one point we decided to call out.
“Hello?”
No response, though I knew it was a longshot.
We discussed the possibility of a power outage,
and what would happen if that were the case.
How long would be be trapped down here?
Was it a good idea to go out on foot?
Before we could come to a decision, suddenly,
the power seemed to kick back on all at once,
and that was when probably the most terrifying.
Thing.
Happened.
The voice chanting, “Dead Men Tell No Tales”
boomed over us as a strobe light viciously
overloaded my retinas.
The shock of those two events would have been
enough to give someone a heart attack, but
what I saw in the light is something that
still chills me to this day.
We were at the shipwreck scene.
If you’re not familiar with the ride, there’s
a portion where a strobe light occasionally
illuminates the image of a skeleton gripping
the steering wheel of a destroyed vessel during
a heavy rainstorm.
The scene is mostly a dark silhouette in front
of the the stormy night sky.
But when lightning struck, there was someone
standing there.
Staring at us.
And I can tell you right now, this was no
animatronic.
I obviously didn’t get a great look at him
in that short split-second, but he had a big
bushy beard.
It was hard to tell if he was even dressed
to fit the ride, or if he was just some guy
in a dark jacket.
Despite only having seen him for a fraction
of a second, I couldn’t get his fiery stare
out of my head.
Almost immediately after this, the lights
shut back off and the audio slowed to a stop.
It was pretty clear at this point that they
were having power issues.
Again, if you’re not familiar with the ride’s
layout, the shipwreck scene is normally only
like a minute past that second drop, but we
had already been floating for at least five
minutes at this point.
Here’s the other thing that bothered me.
That guy I saw.
If that was in fact an employee of the park…
wouldn’t he be helping us out right now
to evacuate the ride?
Knowing that there aren’t usually any live
actors on the ride gave me an uneasy feeling
about seeing the guy.
I wasn’t sure if any of the others on my
boat have noticed, but I didn’t want to
freak out those kids any more than they already
were, so I didn’t say anything.
We sat in near silence for probably another
10 minutes.
(sounds)
I tried using my phone light to scope things
out and see where we were.
I was almost shaking at the thought of seeing
that guy again in the dark.
I surveyed around.
(sound)
Great.
So we had only moved backwards from where
we were before.
After turning my phone light back off, we
sat a short while longer, and as we waited,
I started to notice a splashing that seemed
to be coming from behind us.
Moments later, it started to become clear.
Someone was trudging through the water behind
us, and coming for our boat.
I didn’t want to alarm the other riders,
so at first I ignored it, hoping it was in
my head or something and that it would just
go away.
But it became quite obvious to everyone involved
that there was a person walking directly towards
our boat.
I looked back and my eyes were again met with
an uncomfortably bright light, this time a
flashlight that was pointed up directly in
my face.
My heart was beating out of my chest.
Who was this guy? Was it the guy I had seen
earlier?
My questions were soon answered, by a voice
that called out to us.
“Hey guys, my name is Captain Carter.
Sorry about the inconvenience.
We’re actually experiencing a park-wide
power outage right now, so I’m gonna ask
that you and your entire crew stay seated,
while I guide your ship back to safety.”
The voice was coming from a costumed cast
member wearing thigh high rubber boots and
just walking through the middle of the ride
track.
She actually ended up just pushing our boat
way across the ride to the market scene where
several other ride boats were lined up and
many other cast members with flashlights were
assisting them to a hidden stairway, leading
out of the ride.
I have to admit, they had a pretty efficient
system for getting people out in the event
of an emergency.
Two men in uniform were helping hoist guests
out of the boat and sending them down to the
emergency exit.
While I waited for my turn I had one question
weighing heavy on my mind.
“Uhm excuse me?
Captain Carter was it?
“Yes?”
“I have a question.
When the power came back on earlier for just
a couple seconds…”
“Uh-huh…”
“I saw a guy standing there.
Just looking at us.”
“Oh, that must have been one of the animatronics
coming back on.
Sometimes it takes a few minutes after a shutdown.”
“Are there any animatronics over in that
area though?
Like, by the shipwreck?”
“Uhhhhh, I’m not sure.
I don’t think so, but I’d have to check
on that.”
I would later take to YouTube to confirm what
I saw was not an animatronic.
The uniformed guys then helped me out of the
boat.
I thought I must be one of the few Disney
guests to ever get to walk the area of the
ride scene on foot.
I was the last guest to evacuate the ride
and I was advised to use my phone light, and
follow along the cobblestone until I reached
a staircase which I was to use to exit.
I made it to the stairs…
when I felt that same chill go up my spine...
just as I had before the power had gone out.
I looked all around me.
On my left was the backside of the fake walls
that made up the ride’s backdrop.
It seemed to be used as a little storage area.
The other side was a little pathway for staff
members blocked by a ladder.
So I continued ahead, up towards another staircase.
But before I exited the ride area... before
I got back to my brother and his friend…
Before I walked them back to the car, not
letting them out of my sight for even the
slightest moment…
Before I left that ride area…
I heard the faintest sound emanating in the
distance behind me.
[banjo sounds]
Thanks for listening to Al Dente Creepypasta.
Your total today comes out to $117, but if
you like this video right now, I’ll waive
that fee and give you everything you just
listened to, absolutely free.
I’d like to give a huge thank you to my
collaborators on this video: OST Maker for
composing the music; Elixir, Margbot and Don’t
Turn Around for contributing their narrations;
and Naoya Sakamata for performing this end
theme.
You can find the links to their channels in
the credit section at the bottom of the description.
Let me know in comments what other rides I
should write a scary about, but before you
exit this ride, please stop by our gift shop,
where you can find the new CZsWorld Like Pillows,
with 17 different color options.
Remember to subscribe to CZsWorld for new
horrors every week, ring that deathbell for
notifications and I’ll see you in the next
one.
Assuming we both survive.